je suis ravi de vous rencontrer
je vous ai apporté un magnifique bouquet
de plantes sauvages de notre région
personne n'en veut et vous madame non un
joli bouquet d'orties et de pissenlit
personne n'en veut et oui vous allez me
dire ce ne sont que des mauvaises herbes
qui on voudrait mais moi je les adore et
j'aimerais vous montrer pourquoi
permettez moi de vous raconter
l'histoire de ce bouquet vous me suivez
nous sommes au beau milieu d'une forêt
tout près d'ici
une forêt de bouleaux de fresnes de
chaîne le sous bois abrite des fougères
des ronces dulière la végétation y est
dense mais laisse entrer la lumière
énergie dans cet environnement si l'on
se pose un instant
l'animal qui sommeille en nous se
réveille nos perceptions sont augmentés
un vieux réflexe de proie face à son
prédateur ou un moyen de se laisser
aller à ressentir avec tous nos sens on
entend les bruits le chant des oiseaux
la brise dans les arbres on peut sentir
l'odeur de l'humus on peut voir
l'intensité changeantes des couleurs
selon les rayons du soleil
moi dans cette forêt je m'intéresse aux
plantes des plantes sauvages c'est ma
spécialité
de par mes études et mon métier de
paysagiste mais je me suis surtout
intéressé aux plantes qui poussent
spontanément sans être cultivé
naturellement je suis intéressé à leur
propriété aux interactions qui existent
entre elles à leur fonction dans leur
milieu
j'ai cultivé cette passion et me suis
formé donc à la botanique et à la
permaculture la flore sauvage en france
c'est environ 6000 espèces de plantes de
végétaux qui pousse de même aux endroits
qui leur conviennent le mieux
c'est qu'on a pris l'habitude d'appeler
les mauvaises herbes il y aurait donc
d'un côté les bonnes et de l'autre les
mauvaises herbes
d'un côté les bonnes herbes qui nous
sont utiles et de l'autre celle qui nous
dérange
je voudrais vous inviter à changer de
regard à ne plus penser qu'il y a du bon
et du mauvais dans nature je voudrais
vous montrer que dans cette forêt comme
lors des prochaines étapes de notre
balade les plantes sauvages ont une
importance considérable pour l'ensemble
du vivant dont nous ne sommes finalement
qu'un élément les plantes sauvages
peuvent nous être d'une très grande
utilité
et si on accepte de se décentrer un peu
leur place dans la nature nous paraît
encore plus légitime vous seriez surpris
de voir à quel point les plantes peuvent
présenter d'étonnantes vertus et à quel
point elles peuvent nous être utiles
nous avons perdu un savoir anciens les
plantes sauvages faisait partie
intégrante de l'alimentation de nos
aïeux et faisait partie intégrante de
leur trousse à pharmacie de nombreux
aspects de ce savoir ont été depuis
conforté par la science des études en
biologie en biochimie en médecine en
agronomie on redonner leur place aux
plantes sauvages
replongeons nous dans cette clairière
moussu et dans l'examen de la flore
herbe assez sauvage du sous-bois lortie
par exemple cette plante vivace et
comestibles c'est même la plante la plus
riche en protéines de france est
également très riche en vitamines et en
de nombreux sels minéraux comme la
plupart de ses congénères d'ailleurs
voilà deux bonnes raisons d'en ajouter
quelques feuilles ou une pincée de
feuilles séchées pour cuisiner les
soupes les tartes les gratins lortie est
également une plante médicinale reconnue
en phytothérapie
mais ce n'est pas tout
avec les fibres de l'ortie on tisse des
vêtements avec la styliste qu'elle
contient on fait un dégraissant est
utilisé en purin cette plante fertilise
les sols on peut pas parler des plantes
du sous bois
sans parler du lierre grimpant qu'on
connaît tous contrairement au lierre
terrestre
le lierre grimpant lui n'est pas
comestible mais on en fait du savon ou
de la lessive
car il est riche en saponines cette
liane n'est pas le parasite que l'on
croit il protège les arbres du gel du
froid de la sécheresse et de la chaleur
et elle abrite de nombreuses oiseau
chanteur pendant tout l'hiver en leur
offrant le gîte et le couvert dans ce
milieu toutes les plantes peuvent nous
être utiles même le tronc d'arbre sur
lequel je pourrais m'asseoir qui est
mort abrite une multitude d'espèces
vivantes des champignons des oiseaux
cavernicoles des insectes etc etc
en sortant de la forêt on traverse les
cultures les champs de céréales les
vignes
attardons nous quelques instants pour
observer ces plantes qui poussent
spontanément et subsistent dans les
milieux façonné par les hommes ces
plantes sauvages qui accompagnent les
cultures sont qualifiés d'adventices les
agricultures les agriculteurs pardon ont
pris l'habitude d'éradiquer ces plantes
qui ont élu domicile chez eux sans y
être invitée de peur qu'elles
concurrence leur culture et pourtant ces
plantes qui poussent spontanément dans
les champs sont nos alliés dans un sol
il ya des millions de graines en
dormance ce sont des plantes qui sont à
la fois bio indicatrices elle nous
indique l'état du sol et à son
régénératrice elles sont les médecins de
ce sol là où il ya la maladie
il y a le remède selon les
caractéristiques du sol
certaines plantes vont se mettre à
germer ou non d'ailleurs est anase août
elle nous indiquerons donc l'état du sol
et en même temps elle corrigeront les
déséquilibres de ce sol par exemple sur
un sol très caillouteux ce sera la
pariétaire une petite plante vivace qui
va germer
cette plante à la capacité par ses
racines de sécréter des acides qui casse
la pierre pour rendre le sol un petit
peu plus fertiles et accueillir d'autres
plantes après le pissenlit
cette plante vivace que tout le monde
connaît avec sa grosse fleur jaune
caractéristique va nous indiquer la
présence de potassium en excès dans un
sol ce pissenlit va plonger sa longue
racines dans le sol pour absorber ce
potassium et par là-même désengorger ce
sol qu'elle a ra au passage une
explosion de pissenlit dans un champ est
en fait le symptôme d'une maladie d'un
sol d'un déséquilibre à quoi cela
sert-il de vouloir supprimer un symptôme
sans chercher à traiter la maladie qui
l'a fait apparaître les graines qui sont
en dormance dans un sol vont germer pour
guérir le sol à leur manière elles le
font mieux que nous l'agriculture de ces
dernières décennies a reposé sur l'idée
qu'il fallait supprimer toutes ces
plantes des cultures comme elle a
supprimé pour augmenter les surfaces de
culture avec la mécanisation les haies
champêtres
dommage pour les confitures de murs de
d'églantier deux baies de sureau et
surtout dommage pour la biodiversité la
disparition des fleurs entraîne la
disparition des oiseaux et surtout des
insectes en l'espace de trente ans nous
avons perdu 75% de nos insectes les
insectes
ces petites bêtes qui pollinisent nos
cultures et dont se nourrissent les
oiseaux justement avec la suppression
des haies et des murets ce sont les
chauves souris les perdrix les lièvres
qui disparaissent en l'espace
de 50 ans et même de 30 ans d'ailleurs
nous avons rendu la campagne silencieuse
silencieuse évident de nouvelles
méthodes agricoles plus respectueuses du
vivant émergent
heureusement l'agriculture biologique
commence à respecter la vie moi je me
suis formé à la permaculture la culture
permanente qui propose de travailler
avec la nature et non pas contre elle
la nature est notre meilleur professeur
et dans mon potager où je cultive mes
plantes
je vois pas de nuisibles mais des alliés
quand je vois ces petites plantes qui
poussent en sortant de ce champ en
traversant une petite rivière
on arrive jusqu'à la loire évidemment
traversons la et passons de l'autre côté
de la berge
on arrive en ville un milieu bien
particulier parler de plante sauvage et
biodiversité en ville ça peut paraître
un petit peu farfelue et pourtant même
si elle est souvent reléguée dans les
recoins que lui laisse les aménagements
et l'urbanisation la fleur sauvage n'est
pas complètement absente de nos villes
pour les jardiniers les mauvaises herbes
ce sont ces plantes qui poussent dans
les massifs et dans les talus sans y
avoir été plantés elles sont considérées
comme nuisible à l'harmonie du bien
ordonnée d'un jardin décoratifs
heureusement les lois et les prises de
conscience réduisent le recours à la
chimie pour s'en débarrasser les herbes
folles des villes sont aussi ils sont
aussi très utiles dans ce milieu et à
plusieurs titres
premièrement ce sont des réservoirs pour
la biodiversité
elle attire les escargots les oiseaux
les insectes en leur offrant de la
nourriture mais également un gîte et de
quoi se reproduire
ensuite elle améliore la qualité de
l'air en ville en absorbant le dioxyde
de carbone et de nombreux éléments
polluants elle crée des microclimats on
a tous déjà constaté qui fait beaucoup
plus frais dans un parc ou un square ou
sur l'herbe que sur une route bitumée et
enfin elle améliore le cadre de vie des
citadins
ce qui n'est pas rien nous devons
absolument ramener plus de nature en
ville de nombreuses surfaces peuvent
être végétalisé les toitures les balcons
les petits jardins les terrasses mais
aussi le trottoir et le mur devant notre
porte
toutes ces plantes peuvent nous être
d'une très très grande utilité croire
qu'il y à du mauvais discriminer nous a
conduit à accélérer la disparition de la
biodiversité
pour lutter contre cette perte de
nous devons changer de regard
la nature elle a toute sa place est
partout et le but c'est de comprendre
l'intérêt et l'utilité de cette nature
pour l'ensemble des espèces dont la
nôtre évidemment comme le disait
masanobu fukuoka un microbiologiste
japonais qui a lancé le mouvement de
l'agriculture naturelle la beauté des
fleurs n'est pas leur jolie est en
elle-même mais la capacité du regard que
nous avons porté sur la nature qu'ils
les enfants ce discours pouvait paraître
utopique il y a quelques années c'est
devenu une alerte aujourd'hui j'espère
que pendant ces quelques minutes je vous
aurais donné envie de vous relier un peu
plus à la nature à la nature dans sa
globalité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]